servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und zwar zeige ich
euch heute fünf dinge die mädchen nicht
über jungs wissen natürlich gibt es
einige mädels da draußen wahrscheinlich
wissen dann allerdings sie sich denken
so hell
das weiß man doch aber ich glaube für
die meisten mädels trifft das zu dass
sie das über jungs nicht wirklich wissen
und ich wirklich verinnerlicht haben
deswegen wenn ihr euch bei irgendeinem
punkt dahinter hält es ist auch
offensichtlich ist doch ganz klar dann
schreibt uns einfach unten den
kommentare damit das feedback aufnehmen
kann die fünf dinge die ich heute zeige
habe ich teilweise zusammengestellt dass
irgendwelche artikel teilweise
entstanden die aber auch meinen eigenen
erfahrungen deswegen weiß ich nicht so
wirklich in die wirklich nachvollziehen
können vier punkte die aus meiner
erfahrung sind erkläre ich auch noch mal
deutlicher noch eine sache ich wollte in
diesem video nicht so die üblichen
stammtischs sprüche sowie frauen könig
eilenburg oder sowas bringen weil ich so
was selbst total dem ich finde deswegen
wenn ihr euch irgendein punkt denkt okay
was ist das für ein bullshit das stimmt
überhaupt nicht schreibt es wird in die
kommentare
da kann ich das aufnehmen wollen macht
einfach ich hatte euch den teil fertig
nicht an
punkt nummer eins gedanken lesen das ist
um den was glaube ich zutritt also das
hab ich jetzt schon beobachtet vor allen
dingen umgang mit meiner eigenen mutter
ist quasi nicht nur mädchen und jungs
seien auch frauen und männer frauen
jüngst mütter und söhne generell einfach
weiblich und männlich und zwar habe ich
so ein bisschen das gefühl ich sowieso
weiß was überhaupt nicht kann dass
männer vielleicht nicht so wirklich
zwischen den zeilen lesen können ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass mädels
gerne botschaften so ein bisschen in
direkter packen das heißt sie seien zum
beispiel nicht hacker heute abend das
restaurant let's go keine widerrede soll
die sagen dann vielleicht ach ja derart
in dem mit dem restaurant war so schön
ich erinnere mich noch dran und man
steht also und denkt sich ok interessant
und für ist sofort wieder da können wir
jüngst um ein recht auf wissen was
daraus lernt nicht nur um geld sondern
auch noch mit anderen menschen sie auch
mal zu fragen ob die person und dass er
das gesagt meint sie auch das und das
oder ist er vielleicht irgend eine
andere mutter versteckt punkt 2
auch männer sind unsicher unten auf
absolut verletzlich männer werden der
gerne mal so dargestellt
sich selbst oder als wenig absoluten
verletzlich aufsteiger aus stahl aber
haben wunder selbstständig genauso
emotionen die frauen jungs genauso wie
mädchen und das ist echt gesagt das kann
dass meine eigene erfahrung sagen so ein
bisschen problematisch wenn man
irgendwie so als schwächling dargestellt
wenn man seine emotionen zeigen weil ich
persönlich ein mensch bin der keine
probleme damit hat seine emotion so
zeigen aber ich weiß dass es viel viel
anders geht dadurch vor irgendwie
personen aus einem freundeskreis der
geburtstagsparty hierbei als jungen ich
eingeladen
dann würde man die ich aus meinem
eigenen freundeskreis erfahren habt
vielleicht er nicht sagen so auch man
ich finde es scheiße dass ich nicht
eingeladen hat das macht mich traurig
wird sagen
fakt aber das ist so eine sache jungs da
draußen können auf jeden fall auch eure
emotionen zeigt schämt euch nicht eure
emotionen zu zeigen emotionen sind
menschlich und männlich und es ist ein
falsches bild dass männer und plötzlich
sind punkt nummer drei männer mögen
frauen mit charakter und das finde ich
ist eine sehr sehr wichtige sache zu
sagen weil ich glaube dass mädels immer
so bis nach dem druck sind möglichst
perfekt zu sein möglichst fehlerfrei zu
sein optisch mag los denn vielleicht
noch sich damenhaft zu verhalten los
nicht irgendwie ungehobelt sein über
welche frechen sprüche drauf haben oder
so ich persönlich teil dieser einsicht
nicht mir persönlich und ich glaube
vielen anderen männern gibt es genauso
viele jungs geht es genauso gefallen
dass sie ein bisschen charakter haben so
nur noch 15 mädchen ohne ecken und
kanten finde ich persönlich sehr
langweilig und es geht vielen vielen
anderen auch so das heißt mädels traut
euch ruhig alle ecken und kanten zu
zeigen niemals erwartet von euch
zumindest heute eigentlich mir das
irgendwie den barbie disney prinzessin
seite was natürlich nicht heißt dass man
jeden abend in der kneipe als vor auf
dem tisch liegen sollte
aber ich glaube versteht was ich meine
alle ecken und kanten sind ganz normal
punkt nummer vier und das ist ein punkt
den ich persönlich in meiner erfahrung
gemacht deswegen weiß ich nicht wie von
ihr da draußen euch dazu beziehen können
habe aber die erfahrung nicht nur selbst
gemacht und auch viele viele leute
meinem freundeskreis die gleiche
erfahrung gemacht deswegen dachte ich
mir neben samples video rein auch wenn
ich nicht abschätzen kann wie verbreitet
das ist und zwar ich habe das gefühl es
viele viele jungs zu einem free
pubertären also mit 12 13 14 noch mega
romantisch sind so war ich zum beispiel
wenn dann machen sie irgendwie so die
ersten erfahrungen mit mädels und dann
machen sie ihm so die ersten erfahrungen
mit mädels und meine ersten erfahrungen
waren halt so was von scheiße das kann
man nicht in worte fassen also ging es
viel viel freundin von mir auch und ich
will nicht pauschal sagen dass mädels
die macht dies in diesem alter über
jungs haben missbrauchen oder so aber
ich weiß nicht ich kann nur sagen dass
viele für die jungs in meinem alter
damals diese erfahrung gemacht haben
dass sie zum beispiel in irgend mail
hals über kopf verliebt waren und die
wirklich auf händen tragen wollten und
dann kam so auch nötig weil ich kein
bock auf dich und das ist mir persönlich
noch einmal passiert irgendwo denkt man
sich so das klingt komisch aber
irgendwann denkt man sich daher recht zu
ja was soll der scheiß wenn das nicht
bringt dann dann verschließt man sich
selbst irgendwie so und ich weiß nicht
ob mädels ähnliche erfahrung mit jungs
machen aber die erfahrung haben auf
jeden fall viele viele meiner freunde
auch ich selbst gemacht also dieses
quasi verletzter im frühen alter und da
irgendwie denke ich glaub das wissen
nicht allzu viele mädels über york 2.5
sehr sehr sehr wichtig in der
verständigung zwischen den beiden
geschlechtern es gibt sehr sehr viele
männer oder zumindest für einige ok 22
es gibt wirklich einige männer die ein
frauen einfach nicht nur sexuelle
interessierten aber ich kann natürlich
verstehen dass dieser eindruck bei
frauen entsteht wenn sie nur mit männer
in kontakt kommen ja immer sofort einem
oberflächlichen irgendwelcher art
sprecher sind einfach so gar keinen
emotionalen draht haben und an dem
entsprechen diese mädels und frauen
diesen anruf dass männer sie nur auf
seine sexuelle ebene reduzieren wollen
was aber überhaupt nicht bei allen der
fall ist ich habe persönlich schon von
einigen mädels über die geschichten
gehört von irgendwelchen idioten oder
holen die sofas scheiße behandelt haben
oft hat mich schon die situation erlebt
es sicher wie ganz normale mit einem
mädel irgendeinen kontakt stand und dann
irgendwann kann
du wirst schon genauso wie der an der
und der nicht ich bin einfach ein ganz
normaler mensch und ich habe keinerlei
absicht sich zu verletzen oder irgendwas
aber als mann muss man sich da irgendwie
schon voll rechtfertigen weil es aber zu
viele idioten da draußen gibt die
einfach sich so unverantwortlich
verhalten ja das was von diesem video
schreibt feedback gerne in die
kommentare mit welchen punkten stimmt
die über einen welche punkte für den
tier total hirnrissige bilde gerne
korrigieren bis zum nächsten mal auch
rein und